okay so I'm showing my screen now so
yeah this talk we're going to go through
creation of api's forms and talk a
little bit about how we can develop web
applications at orby provide assistance
to web applications through the Wolfram
cloud so let's kind of jump right in
with some motivation for this so you
know the the big picture for web
development is that we want to share
material with other users right with
people who come to our web pages to look
at them so this could be content such as
text data images graphics graphs etc in
the case of something like an API or
more sophisticated web application you
know we maybe want to have a function
that does an evaluation for some sort of
computation that we're interested in
maybe there's an interactive GUI you
know something on the web page that we
can play with or tinker with to get some
insight about the idea that's presented
on the webpage to kind of these much
bigger scale web applications and we'll
give some kind of mention some examples
and we'll show some examples later on
but you know bigger and bigger and more
sophisticated web pages okay and in
another case that we'll talk about is
just you know if you already have an
existing web application that you've
been developing and you just want to add
some Wolfram language capability to it
this will be giving some tools here
about how to do those computations and
insert them into your existing web
application okay so yeah let's kind of
start with kind of a the basics and then
we'll build from that so right sharing
content on the Internet so the you know
early days of the internet or we have
these very simple web pages with static
content maybe some text some graphics
images and so forth and these are
embedded in this HTML right so this this
is a you know hypertext markup language
so all the information in your web page
is kind of stored in between these tags
which tells the browser how we want this
information to be rendered so I mean
some of you I'm sure I've not played
with HTML at all but this is sort of you
know your very very basic web page what
it would look like so we would
h1 is just a header tag so we'd have a
header that says my webpage and then a
paragraph that says I wrote this webpage
in two minutes and if we save this as a
file and open it up in a web browser we
would see a formatted web page just that
simple
of course this gets much more
complicated in modern web pages and
applications so right these have dynamic
content respond to user inputs a lot of
cases in commercial web sites we would
have advertising that we want to insert
into the page based on the the users who
are visiting the page so just some you
know common examples that I'm sure most
of us really with Facebook Google Gmail
that sort of thing any games that you
would want to play through your browser
would have this type of much more
sophisticated content which requires
another level of programming in order to
make it work so you know not only in
that case would we have HTML in those
pages that we'd also have JavaScript
which would be running on your browser
as data is coming into to react and
respond to to user inputs and and
JavaScript is kind of a whole nother
ecosystem in itself which has a number
of frameworks built on top of it and I
won't go into the details here but but I
mean some of these I'm sure be really
familiar to you guys who are experienced
developers the angular react view and so
forth okay so in the Wolfram cloud what
we're proposing is I you know as either
a means of api's which we'll get into or
as a means of developing your own web
application and so and this is done
exclusively with Wolfram language which
is the programming language behind the
Wolfram technologies so we're going to
create some api's that can be accessed
by any system or user that has access to
the Internet
some web forms that can be viewed
through your web browser as well as some
will form notebooks and and we'll let's
jump into that show what that looks like
so yeah the first thing that I want to
start with is is the idea of a Wolfram
notebook as a web page and so in the
Wolfram
we support that so if you familiar with
desktop Mathematica which is what I'm
using right here to show this
demonstration then what you can see here
is that we could just take this whole
notebook that I'm showing you upload it
to the Wolfram cloud and then it can be
shared with anyone who has access to the
Internet through the Wolfram cloud so
I'm going to do a quick demonstration of
how we can create just a static web page
based on a Wolfram notebook so I'm going
to evaluate this input and this you know
for users who aren't that familiar with
Wolfram language what we can do in
Wolfram languages automatically generate
notebooks and so that's what I'm doing
here with this create document function
we have a at excel that's going to be
have a title format another text cell
that says welcome to this course another
text cell that's saying what I'm going
to plot here which is the sinc function
and then this cell right here is going
to show that sinc function so let me
just evaluate that with my shift-enter
okay and the notebook pops up on my
other screen I'll just drag it over here
so you can see it so here's that
notebook that I just created and and
I've done this programmatically but
alternately I can also add more content
to this if I want so if I want to have
say like the current time that I created
this inside the notebook I can do that
so I'm going to move that off screen and
what I'm going to do is deploy this to
our Wolfram cloud and this is a pretty
simple step with functionality that we
have built into the Wolfram language I'm
going to authenticate with the Wolfram
cloud so generally when you first start
using Wolfram language and get connected
to or endian you want to access the
Wolfram cloud you would pass in your
your password as a second argument to
this function
I've already authenticated so my
password is cached and also this is a
plain text so I don't want to share my
password with everyone who's watching
this presentation right now so when the
response comes back as my user account
for the cloud then I know that I'm
connected and so I can now deploy this
notebook that I've created it's this
this NB right symbol right here is on my
note
object to the cloud and then we'll be
able to access it through our browser so
we have a super function that's called
cloud deploy for sharing a number of
different objects in the Wolfram cloud
so this first example I'm going to show
you is just this static webpage that
I've created so the first argument to it
is that notebook the second argument
which is optional is the path the the
filename that I want it to be saved as
in the Wolfram cloud so I'm inserting it
in a folder called Wolfram you in my
account and then the filename I'm gonna
be calling it first notebook dot dot NB
and I'm gonna talk a lot more about the
third argument further on in this
presentation but this is the permission
so basically just um you know sets
whether or not other users can view this
web page that I've created
so let's deploy this deploys very
quickly so now I have a cloud object
that is returned which is just an
expression in Wolfram language to let
the system know and me know that this is
a file that is stored in the Wolfram
cloud and there's a hyperlink embedded
inside that cloud object which is the
link to that notebook that I just
deployed and if I click on that and it
will open up in my browser so here I'm
in in Chrome looking at that web page
and you can see that that you know this
looks very similar to what I had in my
Mathematica notebook which is here so
this is Mathematica and this is Chrome
over here so I'll slide this out of here
and so this is it a web page now if I
sent you this URL to those of you who
are watching this presentation any of
you could access this web page and or
anyone else you know who has access to
the Internet can access this page and
read it right now live so okay I'll
mention a few other things so we you
know Wolfram notebooks support a huge
amount of styling creating content and
I'm not going to go into much detail in
fact hardly any detail about how that is
done if you're interested there's
certainly lots of resources that we have
available
for teaching how to do that and I just
have another note that that much of the
functionality of notebooks within
Mathematica itself is currently
supported by Wolfram cloud and this is
an ongoing project that's that's under
development is to continue to support
more and more of the features that are
in these Mathematica notebooks so one of
the features that is supported in
Mathematica notebooks is is
Interactive's so here's a very simple
manipulate that I've created manipulate
allows me to interact with an evaluation
so this I'm giving it a simple name
manip and it's a manipulate and
basically a you know I just made this
kind of fun GUI to demonstrate you know
how angry I am today so right now I'm
not angry at all so I'm gonna scale this
down here so Popeye has light-colored
skin but if I click on you know any of
these buttons up on the top and we can
see that the the color of his skin is
replaced with the color that I've
selected here and that's using when our
image processing functions called color
replace okay so now I can also share
this particular manipulate in the
Wolfram cloud much the same way that I
did for the notebook that I created
previously so I'm gonna use our super
function cloud deploy and the first
argument is that object that I've just
created which is this manip symbol and
I'm gonna specify the path to it with
the wrapkin cloud object to show the
cloud where I want this to be saved and
set the patricians
to public again okay so now this is
deployed in the Wolfram cloud so if I
click on the hyperlink here it will open
up in my browser yeah so here I am in
chrome again and so you can see that the
functionality is effectively the same as
what I had in desktop Mathematica but
this is in through my browser and so
again you know if you are very fast
typer you can type in this link and
access it on your own browser if you're
interested let's see I guess while I'm
here there's one thing I want to add
about the the URL to these objects so
that it kind of helps you remember so
you get let's see it's a little bit hard
to see probably but but the URL and
it starts with HTTPS ww-well from cloud
comm and then the next folder within
well from cloud is objects and then some
variant of your username because there's
only one Chad K it seems or maybe I'm
the first Chad K user in the Wolfram
cloud this tells you the cloud that this
is you know my files and then you here
is where you can see the path that I
used in the cloud deploy function well
from you and manip dot NB so this is if
you can remember the first you know the
base URL path then you could just add
the cloud object path to whatever you
typed in and that's that's what you can
send to your browser or of course you
just look at the link that comes back
from cloud deploy you could just copy
that and paste it okay so that's pretty
neat right so we've created both a
static web page as well as an
interactive web page with a couple lines
of code and those are fully functional
web pages that we can share with anybody
okay so now I'm going to move on and
talk about some computations that can be
done in the web the via API so these can
be accessed again through your browser
or through any other software that can
make an HTTP request to the cloud so
this is so the function that that we use
for API is is conveniently called API
function which is analogous to our
function named function so an example of
function right so function the first
argument is the inputs or list of inputs
that go into the function and the second
argument is what we do with that input
so if I evaluate this input here so now
I have a symbol F that has value of that
it is a function that takes an argument
X and squares that value of X so if I
evaluate that that's function f with a
input 3 as squares then it gives me the
shell back is 9 so API function is going
to be similar to that but there's a bit
more sophistication in the way that
inputs are handled because these are
coming through the web rather than
are necessarily through the Wolfram
language itself right so they can come
from JavaScript or any sort of other
programming language that is making HTTP
requests
okay so their inputs and this is not
again not that easy to read but this is
from the documentation so the the inputs
are again it's similar the inputs to our
function of API function the first
argument is going to be as list of name
and type values and then we have our
function and last we have some other
options for how we want this to be
outputted so the name of the of the name
key here inside API function for the
first argument is the parameter name for
an input so this could be you know if
it's going to be a function like we have
above could be X the user name or a city
or building number or anything like that
so basically however we want to define
that symbol inside our function which
we'll talk about in just a second type
is a shorthand for our interpreter
function so the the data that's coming
into our API function is basically a
string and so Wolfram language needs to
take that string and parse it into an
expression that it can be you that it
can use for computations and the way
that's done is with our interpreter
function and there are a number of
interpreter types that are supported for
parsing the data that you bring that
that is brought into these api's so some
common ones that are pretty expected you
know numbers or strings so if I have an
input that's going to use a string that
looks like a real number I can use our
interpreter function with the
interpreter type of number and pass that
input as the argument to that and you
could see that we have the result that
comes back is is this number and if yeah
I'm I'm post fixing that with input form
to show that this is no longer a string
so if there's a string there would be
double quotes around it so I can do an
evaluation on that so another way that
we can look at that is if we want to add
something to it right so that's the
number twenty two point four plus the
number one and it we can just do an
evaluation right on that parse
expression okay so and we can be more
specific than number if we want so if
it's an integer then and what will come
back as is an integer and let's say I
guess I don't have it here but if I do
if I evaluate this you're with with an
input that's actually not an integer
right so in this case I've I've provided
an argument as 12.1 which is not an
integer what will come back as a failure
so this is kind of a helpful way of of
checking to see if the inputs that's
coming into these functions are what we
expect so string is another input so if
we pass a string into the interpreter
and we want to keep it as a string it's
just basically left alone and then once
we get into web actual web applications
then things like JSON are really useful
to have so if we want to pass in a JSON
object to our API function we can do
that as well so I like to use raw JSON
because what comes back is an
association but you can use JSON and I
think there's also JSON expression as
well so in this case so here's my JSON
object as a string right so I'm using
these escape characters to to note that
that a is a string here then it has the
value 3 and B has the value 4 alright so
now I have that as my results and so if
I want to know you know what the value
of the a key is I can evaluate that and
it's 3 where this percent is referring
to this last input and just for fun when
we support a whole bunch of other
different things I'm just showing you it
some other ones so we you know if you
send the bytes for a image file to a API
function we have an interpreter for that
so and this is an example here where I'm
creating the bytes by doing an export
string of a random image that I create
in PNG format and if I pass that through
our interpreter yeah what we get back is
this random image that I created we'd
also have held math expression this is
kind of useful for if you want to have
some sort of online course for having
students answer mathematical questions
right so this is you know they can type
in something that's actually not a
Wolfram language expression and this
gets converted to a Wolfram language
expression and it can be held or not
held so if we want to release hold that
and simplify this expression four plus
three to seven then we get you know sine
of T to the seventh power okay so that's
that's the input part of the API
function now we have I'll talk about the
functions in API functions so here's an
example API function so in this case my
input is the parameter X and it's of
type integer and I'm just going to
square it and so this we're using a slot
notation and ampersand to note that this
is a pure function doesn't a set fee per
bit is a mathematical function and the
the slot tells the system that this is a
parameter that's coming in as an input
and then the label goes right next to
the slot so there's no space between
these two so this is slot X referring to
this argument that's passed into the API
function okay so if I evaluate that so
now the simple API is this API function
and then I can pass in an association
with this key value pair of X going to
ten and actually just probably should
have this as a string all that doesn't
really matter within Wolfram language so
if I pass in ten to my API function its
gets squared and the result is 100 okay
if I pass in now 1.5 and again let's but
that is a string just be more precise
and more web like then I get a failure
because this is not interpreted as not
we're not able to interpret 1.5 as an
integer okay all right and if I wanted
to accept a real number as an input I
would just change the interpreter type
here to a number rather than integer
okay
so here's an example using a string so
I'm just going to do string join on the
name here
and you know add exclamation mark at the
end so here's my my full function that
I'm gonna evaluate so then if I pass the
name as world and we get our classic
hello world evaluation okay
and so just one example here that I just
wanted to show that you know in some
cases using an underscore is supported
as a symbol name in Wolfram language the
the underscore denotes something very
meaningful which is a pattern so we
can't just apply slot to this name but
if you wrap this name leave it in string
and then wrap it with square brackets
then it can be evaluated and and one
other thing I'd like to specify is that
the function that's in the API can be
defined outside of the API so if I want
to define some function get building
data so let's say building 3 will say
that's red and so here's kind of a crude
way of defining this function okay okay
and you can see that so inside my API
function it has this the function name
here without its actual down values but
if we evaluate that again we'll get some
numbers in here and I've only defined
four values 3 & 5 so 5 oops oh right
sorry this should not be this should be
a building number that's the parameter
is not X so this failed why because
there's no input for the field building
number so now if I provide a building
number now you can see that the the
building data here that I've returned is
empty okay so some other notes here that
the function does not have to be a pure
function right so we can't actually load
data or save data at run time and I'm
going to show an example of that when I
get into the forms and the definitions
for any symbols that
used inside the function are
automatically saved along with the API
when we deploy it so right now it you
know because I'm in the kernel session
the you know what you just see here is
that this is pointing to this symbol
name right here but the definitions
because they're in the kernel we don't
need to explicitly point them out here
but when we deploy this to the cloud we
will and I'll show an example of that
for form function okay and so the third
argument for the API function is the
output formats and there's a number of
options for the different types of
outputs and that's described up here and
the the documentation if you go to the
documentation page you'll go see it so
but what I'm just going to show is this
input form where we just specify the
output format for the function we can
have response for Rand format and fail
format and so on but you can read about
that in the documentation I think later
I think we'll just move on about that
but so the output format so you know
some of the common value sets that would
be used again it really would depend on
what your function is returning so
Wolfram language this is a shorthand for
Wolfram language coming back JSON is
supported you could create an image
basically rasterize whatever the output
is or create a notebook cloud CDF is
kind of a shorthand for creating a
notebook so in this example here I'm
going to just output JSON so here's my
input so X is a number and then my
function I'm creating an association
where the first key is just the end
input value and the output value is my
input squared so again it's rather
rather simple functions but much more
sophisticated functions or it can be
supported here this is just a training
class so we're not going to you know
show too many really sophisticated
functions inside this argument so even
though I've specified JSON you can see
that what has come out is actually well
from language expression so if I'm
evaluating an API function within
Mathematica itself then this argument is
ignored so let's deploy this API
function to the
and then we could see that in fact JSON
is being returned so here's my API so
now I need to provide this API with an
input in order to evaluate it so I'm
just going to use some of our tools to
to build get request for this API so
here's my cloud object and I'm going to
provide the parameter value of 4 to that
so now I have a hyperlink that I can
click on and open this in my browser so
now you can see I called this JSON API
with the argument x equals 4 and here's
my output response which is in fact JSON
right so here's my in with value for my
out a value of 16 okay and if again if
you want to do that within Wolfram
language so we can use our URL read
function with HTTP request on this this
cloud object passing the values into it
and look at it and in that case again
you see that this is a JSON string
that's coming back ok so moving on to
form functions so form function like I
said previously is actually I guess I
didn't say this but this is a form so
we're creating a web page that accepts
user input so the structure of form
function in the Wolfram language is very
similar to API function but there's of
course a lot more support for styling
and adding different features to the web
page so just as a quick example I'm
going to show a survey and so in this
survey I'm going well let's see yes if a
survey is that the general idea is I
want to send out a survey to some my
friends and ask them what the best day
for a party in the month of July is so
the 14th the 21st or the 28th so they're
going to see a form on the web where
they could type in their name and then
pick one of these three dates that works
best for them and this is so this
notation here where we wrap possible
options in a list is an alternative to
using our interpreter function so this
denotes that these are the only options
that are supported
for this and this you know generally
would be more appropriate for something
like a webform or we're gonna have a
pulldown menu to look at the options
okay and so this is an example where
yeah this is not a pure function so I'm
going to be saving data and as well as
reading data from another source in this
form that's um you know so what I'm
doing is tracking each person who has
submitted this form their name and then
what their preferred date was and the
return that I'm gonna show them after
they've submitted this form as a bar
chart and so I'm not going to evaluate
this right now because I do have some
data that I've saved in this from
deploying this prior to the course but
if you want to initialize it we could do
that so you can see that here I'm
reading data from this cloud object
using our get function so this is just
basically reading in the data and that's
stored in this file so when I first
deployed this form I initialize the data
as being empty so there's no data in
there and then once the new data from
the user is provided then it gets
appended with this to the data and then
I save it again
and then I do my counting on you know
which dates are work best and provide a
bar chart okay so let me need to play
this form okay so that actually this is
just creating the form now I will deploy
it and so that what I've done here I did
not overwrite this file right here which
has my survey data but I did overwrite
the the form itself just basically
creating a new copy of it okay and so I
can click on that and go to it on my
browser so let's see I'm gonna pick for
Lin who's one of our developers he's
listening right now I think Lin probably
would let's say he wants to go now let's
take out a pic teach July 21st so Lin
picks one of these so you'd see my
drop-down menu for the three options
that I specified and typed in Lin's name
and this is just a string so you should
be able to submit and this should work
and now you see what has come back is
this bar chart with July 14th July 21st
and the 28th and I've only submitted
three times so the one that Lin picked
is now the
hopefully he's okay with that and so
yeah so that again this is an example
where we read data from a file that's
stored in the Wolfram cloud and then
we've saved data to that same file again
now as the owner of this API right maybe
I don't want to go back to the form and
then after you know I've submitted my
favor and I want to know actually what
the data is I don't want to corrupt the
data by adding another fake name to it
so within Wolfram language or in fact if
you want to do this in the Wolfram cloud
you can just evaluate this code to get
the data from there and then this is
just the evaluation that I'm doing
inside the form itself to create the bar
chart
so hopefully this works yeah and so you
can see here's the bar chart in SN
Wolfram language expression that's
that's come back by reading the data
from that file okay so let's see I guess
I'll show this so as an example of a
little bit more complicated type of form
actually mostly as a yeah complicated
form I guess for what you can do in
Wolfram language so our developers have
created the image identify project this
is a machine learning neural network
that can identify various types of
images and I think it's broken here yeah
so I need to upload an image from
somewhere else I guess I could do that
really quick okay so yeah here's a red
panda and let me let's see how can I
should I know
it's over here okay okay so I've
uploaded the the image to this form and
then I get a response back and you can
see that that our internal function or
what language function image identify
has viewed this image and interpreted
that this is in fact a red panda and it
gives me some additional data that's
coming from from Wolfram Alpha so yeah
as a challenge for for some
more advanced users you could think
about you know how would you code the
functionality of this page using form
function okay so guess it's a hint to
get some of you guys going so the first
argument is going to be you know that
the inputs to the function so it's going
to be whatever parameter name you want
to give it it could be image or so forth
and then the interpreter type which can
be you know any sort of image or just
capital eye image like I used in that
previous slide and then you need have a
function in here that does image
identify and then you know so on
whatever level of sophistication you
want to have for sending the data or
telling the user what type of image
they've identified okay we have some
very helpful tutorials for creating more
advanced web forms so I have a link down
here I'm not going to show it right now
but to give a lot more styling more
sophisticated web forms where you might
have more more than one input that's
provided or nested form so you know you
type in one input and then that leads to
you to adding another input and so forth
we also have ask function which provides
a bit more functionality this is still I
believe experimental but if you want to
use or create forms with Wolfram
language that are more sophisticated
than just a single input or you know a
single set of inputs and a single output
we do have tools for doing that okay so
we covered the the basic pieces of that
we're going to be kind of highlighting
later on and but first I want to take a
brief detour to talk about the security
of these deployed webpages and deployed
ap is that we've created so you know in
some cases it's fine to leave them open
so that any person who can access the
URL is able to evaluate them but in
other cases we want to protect the the
data that's inside or or just prevent
other users from accessing them so the
way that that's done is that if your
call from their cloud deploy function is
that third argument has an option
the permissions can be specified in so
there's sort of really high-level
options for for cloud deploy so public
and private being that I think the I
guess like the ones that I've
demonstrated before we're public but
some of the other high level one is
private and then we also have
subcategories that they get depending on
the type of resource that you've you've
deployed to the cloud so
read/write/execute so in the case of an
api rice and maybe you will prevent
users from reading it you definitely
want to prevent them from writing it or
changing some of the code that's inside
but you might want to allow them to
execute so you can specify that that
they can execute only as some examples
of that further down so so if it's
public right then no authentication is
required if its private then only the
owner can access it and the owner must
be logged into the Wolfram cloud so if I
deploy this very trivial API function
which just returns the time right and I
click on this then you can see that that
for me this is working because I'm
authentic ated in the cloud you could
see you go back to the original landing
page for the Wolfram cloud you could see
that I'm logged in here on the other
hand if I go here and I don't believe so
if I use a let's use Microsoft edge I
don't think I've used that so I try to
access it right so if I try to access it
here then I get redirected to the
sign-in page because I'm not
authenticated right and if you are
authenticated in your different user
then you'll just get an error message
saying that you can't even access this
page ok but we also have support for
specific users so if you just have a
list of users that should be able to
view or execute an a viewing a web page
or executing API you could provide that
as an argument to the permissions option
so in this case I'm showing a list of to
users jan well for not common joe at
Wolfram comm and I want them to be able
to execute this API ok another sort of
level of abstraction beyond that so
let's say I have a number of different
API is that or web pages that
I want the same set of users to be able
to have similar types of permissions on
it we can create a permissions group
that has a name and then that the
members of it and then we could just you
know either just set the permissions
with here or we have another function
that's actually if you want to change
the permissions of a deployed API or or
notebook later you can use a set
permissions function and then provide
the permissions as that permissions
group and then provide what type of are
specifying what type of portions they
have so in this case I would provide
read and execute permissions to those
users so one intermediate level of
security that we provide is as
permissions key so this is you know yeah
like I said an intermediate level so the
API itself is open but in order to get
the value of it we need to provide a key
value pair for it so here's an example
of this so again the same thing so we're
going to just return the current time in
this isoh date-time format and the
fruition here is the permissions key and
the argument to permissions key is the
key value itself and so whoever passes
this secret key value has execute
permission so let's deploy this API okay
and now if I make a request for this API
so I you think first here so that I
don't pass in any my authentication
credentials to this API because this is
basically a public API except that it
requires this key value pair and then
the key is this underscore key and then
the value is the value that I specified
above here so if I evaluate this then
you can see I have gotten the response
back now if I pass in wrong key to this
API you see what happens is that right
I'm I'm getting an error message right
so it tells me that I've I passed in an
incorrect permissions key okay so I'm
just doing this post fixing of what
comes back is actually HTML so I just
want to be able to read that nicely and
Wolfram language so I import string as
HTML okay
so that tells me I got it wrong so if I
this is the wrong key if I give it the
right key then I get the correct value
now in the case of notebooks there's
some additional interaction
specifications I won't go into these
very much or even really show you any
examples but but because there's a lot
of different things that users can do
with a notebook we allow more specific
granularity on the types of permissions
that you have from interact which is as
I showed you know if that Popeye example
earlier being able to pick different
buttons for the input evaluate the code
edit it save the notebook create a Cell
delete a cell and so forth
okay so now I'm going to show you an
example that I created for a customer
that involves both calling wolf ricotta
API is for web application as well as
actually hosting it in the Wolfram cloud
which is an option but it's not
necessarily required if you have an
existing web application and you just
want to call well from quality API
that's very viable way to do it but I'm
in this example I'm going to show you
you can actually host it in the Wolfram
cloud so just as a you know word of
caution right if you do need
authentication then your server-side
code nuts does need to perform the
authentication and did you know it's any
on which language you're developing on
the server side you need to pass that
authentication through that language
okay if the output for your API is a
notebook then iframe is a very useful
tool to use so that you just basically
provide a window in your web application
that shows the notebook that's hosted by
the Wolfram cloud within your
application and what I'm going to show
here is an example of that so and
finally the the hosting the full
application so in the Wolfram cloud you
can upload HTML CSS and JavaScript and
then deploy api's you can store data in
the Wolfram cloud as I showed with that
survey example or an MOU from data drop
which I won't go into here and a P is
okay so I'll just quickly go over this
webpage that I created so in
you can see that you know there's it's
kind of a form here which different
options some of these these menus aren't
populated until I've uploaded a file so
this upload file is calls just it calls
one of the api's that I've deployed on
the cloud and this update plot calls a
second API so I've set it up so that I
don't actually need to upload a file so
if I just click on this it calls the API
and now I have options for the different
menus in here so I think if I just set a
couple of these guys yeah that should be
fine
so now I you know basically filled out
the form with kind of a default set of
parameters and now if I click on the
update plot what should happen is that I
get a 3d plot from from the Wolfram
cloud and so this is in fact hosted by
the Wolfram cloud so you can see this is
you know my demo HTML and it's in my
folder well from you in this web app
folder and so the api's are deployed
somewhere in this folder as well if
you're just looking at those I mean you
know we can look at this inspect option
for Chrome and look at Network and you
could see which API is you being called
here but I'm interested of time I'm
going to kind of gloss over that so yeah
so what's come back is this notebook and
why is it a notebook well it's a
notebook because I want to be able to or
that the user actually or owner of this
web application wanted to be able to
manipulate the 3d object so this is one
of the powerful features of the Wolfram
cloud is that if you have a 3d plot you
know we are able to look at it from you
know any angle that we wish okay this is
not just a rasterized view of the plot
okay so yeah again that there's two
api's here and those are both deployed
with Wolfram language there's HTML and
there's a little bit of CSS obviously
not a whole lot there's not much styling
going on here okay so yeah this could be
done it and again that the HTML can be
on a totally different server and you
just need to you know make requests to
that well from cloud if is if you
already have a web application okay on
the other hand and this is some of one
of the ideas that we've been trying to
emphasize about the Wolfram cloud
that you can actually build a you know
full web application with just Wolfram
language right know HTML whatsoever and
that works and that can do some pretty
sophisticated things so one of our
developers Yann pêche co-created some
source code to create a blog in Wolfram
cloud and so here's a link to the
repository I don't really have much time
left so I'm going to leave a lot more
time for Anthony and some time for
questions but if you click on this link
to the repository you can see the code
it's publicly available to to create
your own blog just follow these steps to
evaluate the code it's a Wolfram
language package right so it's all
Wolfram language write a post which is
just a create a notebook in Mathematica
or in the Wolfram cloud if you prefer
either way is fine I'll float that
notebook to the cloud if you've not
created it up there put it in the
content folder of the blog and then
evaluate the following code so which is
basically just sources you know tell the
blog that the sources here's the the
notebooks that I've upload and I'll
click on the links to show you in just a
second to get the sources that you need
amendments or PSA's is actually used as
a kind of a hidden argument to this
deploy function that which then creates
the different formatting that we see so
let me just first I'll show you my first
post here so this is just a notebook
that I created in desktop Mathematica
and then I upload it to the cloud so but
you can see that yeah here's in the
content folder which is what Yuans
instructions told us to do and it's very
very simple right so it's just one text
cell and then this now evaluate our now
input cell which in fact I think that I
can't evaluate because the permissions
of this notebook again this is something
I've talked about in that permissions
page it's not set for evaluating cells
so but okay so that's the notebook that
I upload it so now let's look at the
blog in its current state and again I'm
not showing you the details of how this
is created hopefully you'll have a
chance to take a look at this on your
own time so you can see that what what
has been done here is that the only
thing that you know that I've done on my
end you
is to create and upload these notebooks
and then the code that Yanis created has
assembled those notebooks into a single
index notebook page where we can click
on you know read more to look at the
full post so I always showed you the
first post which is not very useful but
so I look at the back for more posts I
can click on this read more link which
will open a tab to the full notebook
that that the full Knoblauch content
that was created but also it has the
header still for the blog and and the
interesting thing here as well as that
so we can have an interactive in here so
and you can saw on the last one that you
can't evaluate inputs but the default
permissions for for this blog are that
that you can interact with it so this is
a you know a working web page with
Wolfram language evaluation that can be
interacted with and then we can leave
comments in it as well which is kind of
fun so if you can access these URLs or
create your own blog then people can
comment on it right ok and there there's
a lot yeah a lot of details that I'm
really glossing over here so I hopefully
that you have some time to take a look
at at this repository and and take a
look at the code yourself so you know
for those of you do that you know some
of the things you can think about like
what could be done to improve the blog
and maybe you could pass on those
suggestions to yawn or a cloud developer
team so in conclusion so the Wolfram
cloud supports multiple architectures
for web applications so we've seen that
where we we support API functions form
functions standalone notebooks notebooks
can be bundled right we can have
external web applications evaluate API
is that are hosted on the cloud any of
these sorts of things are supporting the
Wolfram cloud and here's some link to
some resources that are available
there's a whole bunch more that I'm not
really listed here but yep if you
haven't tried them often called be sure
to try it out we we have a free open
cloud that yeah this is open to anybody
that you can try and do some of these
evaluations that I've shown in this
presentation